wait a minute is any of my friends gonna
watch this i don't know
i don't know
[Music]
hi jack and james i'm corey hi i'm dan
hi dan
james tell me who your favorite
character in the whole movie was
what did you like about ian he was the
only who could do
magic that's right very cool if you guys
could do magic what would you do
i would make a cheese puff as big as
sand
that's huge sand is huge i like food
good point you know what ian wanted
in the movie yes his dad that trying to
bring their
dad to life but all they get is pants
and
butt we didn't even know that much
making the movie that's great
you guys made the movie oh no
just kidding how did you write the movie
we all worked together and made up the
movie based on
my big brother and it was onward is
there a character in the movie that
reminded you of your brother
charlie because jack knows where he's
going sometimes
i never know where i'm going hey jack
do you have a favorite scene in the
movie well i'm gonna need to act it out
ian fell down the cliff
luckily the rope pulled him up and then
morally said
was that the worst that can happen are
you
dead yet no so now you know the worst
that can happen so there's nothing to be
scared of right
if you guys were giving awards would you
give onward
an award of any kind yes for best for
best
wizard movie ever yes
how did the ending make you feel normal
well jackie james thanks so much this
was so fun
um we gotta say goodbye now
you